[Musik]
und dann kannst du auch mal die beine
ist nach oben nehmen zum himmel ein
bisschen aus strecken die arme zu nehmen
und auch richtig so fußgelenk heraus
schütteln handgelenk heraus schütteln
bewegen aus der hüfte heraus die beine
bewegen die arme ellenbogen schultern um
auch richtig alles raus schütteln alle
anspannung raus allen druck raus ja wohl
kräftig und alles raus ja wunderbar sehr
gut
ba management tätig im großen
internationalen konzern
ich habe gemerkt über die jahre hinweg
der druck wird einfach zu groß ich
arbeite sehr viel und ich entferne mich
immer mehr so von meiner essenz viel
geld verdienen immer höhere rendite mehr
mehr profit die klassischen themen in
der wirtschaft und die befriedigung
wurde immer weniger
am ende ist es kumuliert den
körperlichen ich bin krank geworden hab
dann die klassischen stresssymptome
bekommen verspannungen druck
schlafstörungen aggressivität und dann
auch eine schwere gehirnblutung bekommen
und das war für mich ein zeichen dass es
so nicht mehr weitergeht
[Musik]
seine schultern dürfen ein stückchen
mehr zum boden sinken weich werden
[Musik]
die zentrale ist es an sich zu arbeiten
sich weiter zu entwickeln oder man
könnte auch sagen so ich selber zu
optimieren
ich glaube ich schon sehr essentiell es
ist die frage mal in welcher phase
meines lebens stehe ich wo stehe ich
gerade habe ich die ressourcen dazu habe
ich die kraft dazu habe ich die zeit
dazu und oft was ich beobachte ist der
druck auch groß genug um etwas zu ändern
und es braucht schon auch immer wieder
an einfluss von außen muss etwas
passieren damit ich für mich reflektiere
geht so weiter möchte ich so weiterleben
oder kann ich etwas an mir ändern
mein mann trat es nicht mal gehört hab
von meiner mutter ich liebe meine mutter
ihr wisst ja auch was sollen denn die
nachbarn denken du mit deinen
verrissenen rosen und die komische musik
die du da hörst und ein komisches auto
wurden probiert dosen drin also ich war
als pubertierender ist halt so ist
damals auf dem dorf was sollen denn die
nachbarn dinge aber wenn ich das
natürlich so absorbieren so angepasst
lebe ich ja nicht mein leben sondern das
leben von meinem nachbarn ja ich mache
mir nicht lustig über diese menschen er
versteht das nicht weil wenn diese
prägung so stark sind ist schwierig da
rauszukommen
also ich erkenne diese prägung diesen
glaubenssatz und jetzt üblich denn
anzunehmen ich will halt beliebt sein
ich kann nicht nein sagen oder ja ich
bin halt pedantisch ich bin perfekt und
ich muss das jetzt alles zum 13 mal
nachrechnen
das ist jetzt so und dann übe ich eben
das umzuwandeln
möchtest du nach vorne kommen genau
möchtest du dich mal so hinstellen wie
du dich wohl fühlst so ist der abstand
zur unordnung ganz die augen schließen
und ganz bewusst jetzt die füße
wahrnehmen ist in kontakt haben mit dem
boden
die aufrichtung wahrnehmen
schultern aussortieren für den
hinterkopf noch ein stückchen mehr nach
hinten und dem war wie du jetzt da
stehst geehrten kraftvoll ganz stabil
fest
und während du so atmest bist du ganz
bei dir
es liest jetzt sitze vorn dass diese
sätze einfach mal auf dich wirken
schauen was passiert
ich akzeptiere was ich nicht ändern kann
ich muss nicht alles kontrollieren
störungen sind teil des jobs ich bleibe
gelassen auch wenn ich nicht weiß was
kommt gibt es da einsatz bei dem du eine
resonanz spürst einsatz der dich
anspricht
möchtest du ihn sagen irgendwie alles
kontrollieren
sehr schön sagt den satz noch mal in
deiner mundart so wie es für dich
stimmig ist
tief einatmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und sagt den satz nochmals kontrollieren
sagt einsatzleiter im monat auskommen
soll jeder noch lauter er muss nicht aus
kontrollieren und kräftig laut ich muss
nicht auskommt oder dickmann seine linke
hand auf dein herz und die rechte hand
auf die linke an und sagt den satz noch
mal sind aus kontrollieren
ja
und doch mal so vielen herzlichen dank
für die schöne übung das hast du
wahrgenommen über verlauf der übung den
satz wie lautet ein satz immer wieder
kontrollieren den wiederholst du jetzt
jeden tag kannst du diese post it zettel
klebst du auf dein kühlschrank drauf was
steht auf dem posten zettel drauf da
gehst den sparte zimmer schränke und
macht seinen spiegelschrank auf und
erklärten post-it mit was für umsatz und
dann machst du deine wurzeln eine
schranktür auch vom kleiderschrank
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und je mehr ich in die ruhe komme je
mehr ich eben diese gedanken zu hohe
bringen den geist zur ruhe bringen desto
mehr komme ich immer mehr bei mir an und
gerade in unserer gesellschaft die ihm
sehr stark geprägt ist durch materielle
dinge durch materiellen wohlstand durch
glücksversprechen im außen ist es nicht
einfach und oft erkenne ich auch wenn
ich mit meinen klienten auch intensiver
zusammenarbeit ich liebe orte des
rückzugs einfacher im kloster dort
blühen sie auf
[Musik]
also ich hatte ein schlüsselerlebnis das
nicht sehr stark geprägt hat sich wurde
schwer krank und lag im krankenhaus und
das war nicht glaube ich diese nacht
überleben
und ich hatte eine ganz tiefe ruhe ganz
großen frieden und das war das erste mal
wo ich gespürt habe ich kann es nicht in
worte fassen damals nicht heute nicht wo
ich gespürt habe es wird alles gut oder
es ist schon alles gut und es war für
mich schon eine wichtige erfahrung dass
ich vertrauen darf
und das war für mich auch eine wichtige
erfahrung dass da etwas ist was ich
lange lange gesucht habe auch wenn es
nicht in worte fassen kann und das
möchte ich näher kennenlernen erkunden
[Musik]
kommt meine arbeit bei den leuten an
ich glaube schon es ist ich vergleiche
wie so ein kleiner samen der gepflanzt
wird oder gesät wird und aus diesen
samen kommt ein kleines pflänzchen und
es muss gegossen werden gehegt werden
gepflegt werden und irgendwann kommt da
vielleicht ein bisschen raus und
irgendwann eine kleine blüte und das ist
so sehe ich auch meine arbeit ich kann
am ende kann ich keinen menschen helfen
und retten und das ist auch nicht mein
anspruch das wäre vermessen
was sich menschen mitgeben kann ist eben
eine andere sichtweise ich kann ihnen
eine erfahrung schildern ich kann ihnen
übungen mitgeben techniken ich kann ihn
sichtweisen zeigen aus den asiatischen
business lehren
ich kann sie zum nachdenken anstoßen ist
der platz hier ok möchte dich
woandershin legen ja wo möchte sein kopf
hingegen hier oder genau dann bringe ich
dir noch einen kopfkissen oder eine
decke hast du uns sensiblen rücken
also möchte was unter die knie nehmen
ist das gut so
möchtest du dich zu decken ok und dann
mal ganz bewusst jetzt hier ankommen in
dem körper den körper wahrnehmen noch
wahrnehmen wie dein körper jetzt schwer
wird kiefer ist locker deine zähne
bewähren sich nicht
das lastet auf der auf dem rücken
das besondere hier hast du da
14 15 wo stehst du jetzt in diesem
elternhaus in deinem zimmer des
einsturzes soll es allein können wir
auch darum wie sie das ist meine sache
geschwiegen
was braucht die partie jetzt in dem
moment wo sind da steht in diesem zimmer
weiß es einfach viel zu viel so viel
schulaufgaben schaffen dann für den
vater noch da sein müssen oder wollen
jetzt auch die pet gleich nicht gab und
cluster möchtest du jetzt als starke
erwachsene frau mit der ganzen kraft die
du hast jetzt zu der partie gehen und
seefest den arm nehmen
und sagen dass du für sie da bist ja
gott was derzeit
wie reagiert sie
sie ist
beide teams nahmen ein sind ja man darf
sie weiter
dann lasse ich jetzt mal geschlossen hat
immer ganz bewusst tief durch die nase
ein bis er den bauch kraftvoll
und am ende kräftig kraft noch nicht
langen dior den kopf hinterkopf kräftig
alles glücklich rein
die schultern arme richtig aus streit
mit dem körper alles weg und alles noch
mehr alle wie gut alle trauer aller
schmerz weg weg
wasser wasser zeigt
wo stehe ich auf meine reise eine sehr
gute frage ich
ich sehe mich am anfang
ich glaube das ist nicht abgeschlossen
es ist ein ständiges lernen dass und
ständiges erfahren und auch immer wieder
sicherlich auch mit rückschlägen
verbunden auch mal mit phasenweise im
stillstand aber kontinuierlich
entwickelt sich etwas
also war könnte salopp sagen haben ein
zusammenbruch ja war schon noch mein
glück dass es eben da eine neue tür
geöffnet hat sozusagen ihr wollt das ist
jetzt etwas mit der erfahrung die ich
gesammelt habe im positiven wie im
negativen
kann ich jetzt einen schritt weiter
gehen und kann jetzt etwas tun was sie
eben andere menschen auch hilft was sie
unterstützt was ihnen vielleicht
orientierung bietet
[Musik]